we're entering an era in which our
enemies can make it look like anyone is
saying anything at any point in time
they could have me say things like I
don't know kill monger was right ben
Carson is in the sunken place now you
see I would never say these things but
someone else would someone like Jordan
Peele
this is a dangerous time moving forward
we need to be more vigilant with what we
trust from the internet that is creepy
and that that video shows oscar-winning
filmmaker Jordan Peele putting words in
the mouth of former President Obama it's
part of a new public service ad campaign
to warn Americans about the growing
threat posed by digital misinformation
Carter Evans shows us how the US
government is trying to respond to this
new technology it's really easy to do
these kinds of things to manipulate
images and video Dave Dorman is project
manager at DARPA
it's the secret Defense Department
agency trying to keep the country a step
ahead of cyber threats is the ability to
manipulate video a threat to national
security I think absolutely I think
that's a very important national
security concern it can cause unrest
it can cause riots other nation states
could even act on some of this stuff at
DARPA Dorman put us in a conference room
and confiscated our phones for security
we then took a look at the software he's
developing to identify the new
generation of fake news it's fairly hard
to tell what was manipulated in this
particular image and if I go to the next
slide here it's gonna have a transition
where it's showing you the process the
bright red means the car is not really
there so let me go on to something's a
little more complex here when in the
course of human events the blue line
here is the audio of the first speaker
and then it detects that there was a
second speaker which I've connected them
with another so it's detecting the
changes there there it's detecting the
changes my vision is to have a program
that every image every video posted to a
social media site go through this
process for CBS this morning Carter
Evans loss
Angelus thinking about the next next
presidential election on this sort of
technology which is really scary for
everybody be on notice about it yeah and
once you see it you can't unsee it even
if you know it's not real it's a new
level of fake news it's right name